In the third season of "Yellowstone," viewers
finally learned the source of Beth's animosity
toward her brother Jamie.
A flashback shows they were close as teenagers,
and Beth turned to her brother for help when
she discovered she was pregnant.
Jamie's solution was to take her to the abortion clinic that serves the region's indigenous population.
Jamie is informed that the procedure will
amount to sterilization for Beth, but he goes
ahead and consents on her behalf.
He doesn't even tell Beth about the consequences.
When she finally learns the truth, she can't
forgive him.
Time notes that many Native American women
were sterilized, legally and without their
knowledge, at reservation abortion clinics
in the 1970s.
But that practice ended well before Beth would
have been getting her abortion.
It's also hard to believe that Jamie would
be allowed to consent for his sister since
he's not her parent or legal guardian.
Plus, considering that the clinic staff seem
to recognize them as children of the powerful
Dutton family, it seems like they'd at least
mention this to Beth before going through
with it.